ce n'est pas mon fils c'est juste un corps que je
nourris et lave et habille Je suis Mary salut dr.
Wilson House s'occupe même de la même chose que la
semaine dernière une semaine avant que je ne le perde ce jour-là, j'ai
perdu Richard dans la voiture là-bas, le prochain
patient vous attend dans le bureau,
il fait face à beaucoup de chagrin après
la mort de sa mère, ils le déménagent à
Boston  est-ce vraiment nécessaire qu'il puisse
simplement rester ici c'était comme si j'avais
récupéré mon petit garçon
salut Mary salut pour vous dire la vérité je pense
qu'un sera bon pour nous tous
Wow les
autorités ont déclaré que l'
enfant disparu n'aurait pas pu survivre à la
chute sévère  dans les températures je me sens si coupable
tu ne peux pas te blâmer je n'ai pas très
bien dormi j'ai vu Tom mais
tout le monde dit qu'il est mort tes
problèmes de sommeil te rendent difficile
de distinguer tes cauchemars
de la réalité il ne se passe rien
Stephen s'étire  son visage
écoute ce que tu dis tu parles
de fantômes il se passe quelque chose et
ce n'est pas que dans ma tête je peux le prouver
tu dois me croire
vrai
toi